hey y'all it's andrew couch here and in
this tight tuesday video we're gonna be
focusing
on multi-class classification models
so i was reading you guys comments and
um in one of my classification videos
someone wanted me to talk about
multi-class um classification metrics
which is actually a pretty good idea
because um generally when you're looking
at all these classification
machine learning problems they're always
like perfectly balanced
uh binary classes when in reality
um it's generally you're going to see a
lot of multi-classes that you're trying
to predict
but they just are converted into a
binary outcome
so i figured we would kind of go over
this
this type of problem dealing with a lot
of problems that
arise with multi-class classification
while also throwing in
some nlp modeling um so i was looking at
the text recipe package and i figured
it'd be fun to do
some more complex nlp modeling so
extending
like engram analysis to like word
embeddings and
um text hash like hash features and also
doing some uh
um cool like word event algorithms too
uh
using the text data package so i figured
i kind of i would kind of just combine
two interesting things uh multi-class
classic classification
and more advanced nlp modeling
okay so i'm gonna load in um i mean i'm
gonna open up an r markdown and i'm
going to call this tidy
tuesday multi-class
classification and for our data set
we're going to actually use a data set
that i uh created with a
side project i was working on last year
i'm going to do tidy verse uh
what's your oops
i'm gonna load in tigers tidy models
uh text recipes which is
i'm just extra recipes for the text
processing
i'm going to load in the text data
package i'm also going to load in the
themis package
okay and we're also going to read in a
harry potter csv
so first let's just go over the actual
data set
before we go over the individual
packages and what they do
so this data set was a data set i
created
uh using screenplay and um
book data from the harry potter series
and essentially each line
is a character and their dialogue
okay with the labeled class uh with a
labeled house
the book and the character name in this
case we're only going to be selecting
the
house and the text and if we actually
count the
houses um i included some people who
were like muggles or uh not in a house
so we're gonna have to filter that out
i'm gonna say filter else does not equal
no entry okay so now we have all our
text data
cool so let's go over the packages
that we're going to be using today the
first one is going to be tidy verse
which is pretty straightforward tidy
models text recipe
which is essentially just recipes that
um deal more with nlp modeling and text
analysis
so it's a cool um pretty common um nlp
stuff like
stemming words removing stop words token
filtering
engrams tf idfs etc um
we're also going to be using the text
data package and the text data package
is where i loaded in
basically these word embeddings um it's
pretty cool because you can use like
the glove embeddings um they also have a
decent amount of data sets so that's
where i'm going to
use this is the source of the word
embeddings i'm going to use
which is essentially kind of like a
some more advanced types of um features
that we can produce out of these words
so then let's see our other one and then
our last package that we're going to be
using is the
themis package and this is going to deal
with class imbalances
so um let's just actually look at our
classes
again since we filtered out the houses
to the relevant harry potter houses and
we can notice one thing
where it's highly imbalanced towards
gryffindor right
so which makes sense because in the
books and in the movies it's focused on
the main characters who are all from
gryffindor
um so let's just do a little plot
right so it's highly imbalanced and that
this is a problem
i think is pretty common in
classification problems
specifically multi-class classification
problems where we have
uh one class that's uh very prevalent
and the remaining classes aren't as
prevalent
so you're gonna have to deal with this
these problems usually it might not be
as skewed towards one class but this
is pretty easy to fix since we have a
lot of samples
we can do some basic sampling for it
okay um yeah we have about 14 000
samples so that's fine okay i'm also
going to show you how to get the
um the word embeddings
um so if i do was a text data
and then i do a embedding if you uh run
this command
you can it'll download the word
embeddings so
download word embeddings okay
but we don't have to really worry about
that okay
so let's actually just do the um
training test splits first
so create train and test
set splits so i'm going to set the c
to the 19 initial
split um df and then we'll stratify
based off the classes
so we'll do that we'll create our
training data which will be
uh training
initial oops that's why i'll call us a
tidy split
and then our we'll create our train data
our testing data
and then our k-folds data
okay so we haven't done
any clasp we haven't done anything where
we wanted to balance our classes
and this is something where we kind of
have to make a decision
so on one hand we could uh
rebalance the classes before we do our
pre-processing or we could pre-process
our data
and then balance the uh
the features of the classes
and in most cases i would say we should
go with the former where we want to
basically
rebalance the data and then apply the
pre-processing
because when you're doing the
pre-processing especially with um
um ml when you're doing complex
pre-processing you're essentially
i'm looking at data that hasn't been
seen before
we're giving it to like a k-fold model
so in this case we're actually going to
be i'm pre-processing the data first
and we're only pre-processing the train
data so with our trained data we'll just
say train
data recipe
house data equals train data
and we'll say step down sample
house we'll prep it and then we'll
choose it so
we'll just apply the down sampling to it
okay and if we look at our trained data
and then we count our house we can see
that we have
a balanced data set so it's pretty
straightforward
and we can also see that we have way
less data he's essentially removed a lot
of the
majority classes through sampling
and that's why we we that's why we down
sampled because we didn't have a lot of
classes
for the um other minority classes
and we had a lot of them in the majority
class so that means that
we're willing to sacrifice some of our
majority class
so that it can even out our minority
classes
so you can decide between down sampling
up sampling and there's also
other um ways to do it
so step like smote rows are very common
but i don't i don't really want to go
too much into it um
the basic things is either down sample
or up sample depending on your data
um in this case i'm fine with down
sampling i think down sampling could be
kind of like
the default thing for um dealing with
class and balances but i'm no expert on
all the algorithms that go into it but
we're just going to do that
so we have our data that's been
rebalanced
for our training sets and now let's
create
some recipes so the first recipe we're
going to create
is this one and i'll say we're going to
be predicting house our data will be our
terrain data
we want to tokenize our stuff our
we want to tokenize our text so step
tokenize our text um i want to also
uh stem the text
so if it's essentially just shorting any
words that have extra stuff so
like dogs would become dog etc
i'm also going to do step stop words so
i'll remove any
random stop words and also do step token
filter and in this case we'll say max
tokens is equal to one thousand okay so
if we did this
um we would see that we have
um we're gonna have a lot of tokens and
that'll be very bad for what we want to
do
especially if we do like step uh tf
text right it's gonna take a long time
and we're gonna have a very wide data
set
which is kind of a huge problem when
you're doing a lot of modeling
see we have a thousand columns by a
thousand uh by about 1400 rows
and that's very bad because we could uh
we don't have enough data for this and
generally you don't want to have more
features than your samples
so what i'm actually going to do is i'm
going to use a step
text hash and we're going to say the num
terms will be 100
text oops text num terms is equal to
100. so this
essentially kind of combines a lot of
these features
using some type of hashing function um
but we do a uh wrap
juice we can see we only have a hundred
columns
over the 1400 features obviously we
don't have any interpretation between
like these actual words it's just hash
one two and three
but um we reduced a lot of our features
we could also do like maybe a pca uh or
something like that or some type of
clustering or even do like an
uh near zero variance um
removal but i'm fine with just using
this text hashing so i'll say hash
track right there okay
and now let's do um a more complicated
word embedding so
i'll do recipe house it equals train
data
and essentially we can just use most of
this stuff so right here
okay and then what we can do is step
word embeddings
give it our text and give it our
embeddings in this case we're going to
be using
our word embeddings from the text data
package so i'll say embedding
glove27b right
um so if i do prep and juice
it'll create some word embeddings for me
right
and this is a little bit uh more uh
informative
because we have a little bit more um
variance and
in our features because essentially it's
using like
um it's using other models that were
created using a lot of data
and trying to basically map them out
into a
um a simpler space um which is like the
main ideas of
uh word embeddings i think the classic
example is like the
i think word to vec algorithm where like
they show the example of like
how a king would be mapped next to a
queen because there are similar things
um but we don't really need to worry
about that so we have our embeddings
wreck right here and we're going to
create our recipe
okay so now it's actually just definer
models and most of the
tidy models actually have multi-class
support but i'm going to show kind of
like the
the common models you might be using for
a multi-class classification
first we could do a logistic regression
which is actually
a multinomial so multi-gnome
reg and we'll say penalty is tuned
and we'll say mixture is one so
essentially it's like a multinomial
lasso regression model um setter
engine to gm net set
mode to classification
okay another model that works um with
multi-class classification problems is a
k n nearest neighbor
so i'll do that i personally really like
k n models because they're pretty
straightforward and they offer a lot of
support for
classification uh regression
and multi-class classification
also um i i've watched i've watched some
videos of people using
k-nearest neighbors models for a
computer vision which is pretty
interesting too
um so let's make a classification model
and then finally i'll just do a actually
boost model which um
supports multi-class classification
problems
um i will say uh actually boost
is very slow with multi-class
classification models
uh problems so if i were to do this
again
i would definitely use like a random
forest which also
supports these types of problems
okay so we have our models
okay i'll actually say i got
pre-processing reprocess
x data okay um now we're just going to
define our grids so i'll say
um define grids
so logistic grid will just be like
a regular grid given a certain
list of parent list of penalty
parameters so
parameters uh logistic
model i'll say levels
is equal to three okay
for our k n grid we'll do the same thing
um k n model levels is equal to
i don't know five if we look at our k
n grid it has one neighbor which will
definitely to overfitting so i'll just
say uh
maybe filter is equal to neighbors
is greater than one which i think will
just remove it okay so
it'll just remove it that's fine um and
then we'll do actually boost grid
parameters actually boost model
levels equal to three
and again with our cheap boost grid i
want to remove those
trees that are just one so i'll say
filter
c freeze is greater than one
oops oh
there you go okay so now we have our
grids
great and then we're going to also
define our um
uh define um tuning process
so with our tuning process i want to
specify our model control
the model control will be a control
grid save the predictions because we
want to evaluate the predictions based
off the confusion matrix
we'll also do the model metrics which in
our case will do your generic accuracy
sensitivity specificity mean
log loss and the roc aoc
score so with tiny models
uh specifically with the
[Music]
yardstick package they do offer a
multi-class support for these uh
for these parameters so with roc aoc
they essentially have a different
evaluation than your traditional binary
metric but they try to accomplish the
same thing
okay so for our grid i actually already
um created these um
i already tuned these models um in this
case we're tuning essentially six models
because we have two pre-processing
functions
with three models so i'm just gonna load
it using
the uh multi dot our
data
okay obviously with this this tuning
it's pretty straightforward so i'll just
say tune
models and i actually have this little
um i'll just copy and paste this in it's
really not that interesting so i'll just
do that
and these are our tuning of the models
that we don't actually have to run for
so
we'll load that if you check we can see
our
and now we have our actual files and it
didn't take too
long so let's actually look at our
models
so look at our hash res we'll just say
collect
um metrics
um i'll actually just bring in all these
models in
so our k ns are actually boost
our embedded models
okay so let's just paste these in i
could actually do a
map function but this is pretty easy too
okay so let's actually say uh show
s and in this case i want to look at the
roc aoc scores
okay
so we have our best roc aoc scores and
let's actually look at the models so
0.69 is our highest one
0.62 0.75 so our xg boost model is
definitely
better um again with the layer
embeddings
against or or the word embeddings we can
see that on the
it's it's not fitting as much then we
can see right here
same scores and then we can see right
here how basically our embeddings model
did not do as well as we hoped it to be
hoped it
to do so we're just going to stick with
our xgboost
hash res model that's fine we're going
to do that
and what i'm actually going to do is i'm
going to say slice 1 and i'm going to
select
the final params so trees and orange
rate so
select so these are the final params
and with actual evaluations of uh the x
of like multi-class classification
problems it's good to always look at the
actual confusion matrix
which is why we have why we kept uh why
we specified in our model control that
we wanted to save our predictions so
we write see right here if we say save
pred and throw into our control
it'll save all of our predictions within
our samples so let's do that so let's
say
collect predictions
and i'll say enter join final
ram it was joining by the trees in
orange or aka just selecting the best
model
and then what we can do is we do a group
by
our id and we do a confusion matrix
within comp
mat so
truth is equal to house estimate is
equal dot
[Music]
class now we have a list of confusion
matrixes
um we can tidy the confusion matrix
using
the tidy function so off that
tidy and then we can just say
unnest tidied
and now we have all this um which is
in the uh in the uh the confusion matrix
um but it's not that interesting right
now because it's not in a great format
so if we actually go back
and just say uh off matt
um which i'll just leave this in
right here
right here and i'll say uh conf matt
truth
is equal to house estimate is equal to
dot
class it'll show us our confusion matrix
i'm in it in a tidy format and this can
this right here is showing um a pretty
pretty good score for our multi-class
classification
um we can see here this is our truth or
what
the actual house um the character
belongs to this is the actual
and this is what our model is predicting
so with gryffindor it's pretty good
um maybe i can actually tidy this let's
try it out okay nope i don't wanna do
that
so we can see how um we're doing pretty
good with our our
model um we see it's very good at
predicting
slytherin and hufflepuffs um and
additionally it's pretty good
at um doing gryffindor's but it's not as
good as predicting a ravenclaws
and now we can see like when it actually
predicts um
gryffindor like where is it actually um
the correct prediction at in the truth
so we can kind of see these crosstabs of
like
when we have a prediction how how
confident we can be
in that prediction being true and what's
the second likeliest option
so let's actually look at our our
gryffindors
so when it predicts gryffindor uh
um usually it is correct however
sometimes it
appears to be ravenclaw which is
essentially tied with a ravenclaw and
slytherins
um if we look at our truth we can see
like okay like
you know uh given um the correct
gryffindors how what are they miss um
classified as so
for gryffindor students most of them are
um actually classified
if as slytherin okay
so it's pretty interesting just to read
all this
if you kind of go through gryffindor or
hufflepuff and ravenclaw
the most um um misclassed
glass is essentially the slytherins
because
these gryffindors half loss of
ravenclaws
second um most predicted class besides
their true class
is uh slytherin so that's pretty
interesting about the model
so let's actually finalize our model um
using our
uh let's create our final workflow so
say final
model is equal to workflow
add model which will be the
xgboost
model add recipe which will be the
hash recipe
and i'll say finalize uh was it
workflow and give it the um
final param i believe finalize workflow
with the final
model and prem
okay so i'll give that to the final
model
and now let's evaluate our final um res
so
final res is equal to last fits
final model and then tidy
split so we don't let that run
so uh tune um evaluate
final model and say evaluate
a model um evaluate i'll say confusion
matrix
and then with the final model we'll
evaluate all of our metrics
and see what how good the model actually
is
uh notice that we're using a uh
a balanced data set for our training
data but
for our final last fit or for our test
data
our test date is actually in balance
because that is what is representative
in our population sample
so let's see if it's still going
and then let's see here what else can we
look at
so also with with i'll just go over the
uh themis package too
and also the yardstick package so with
theme is the most
uh it's actually just recipes to deal
with class balance imbalances
and when you're doing these um adding
these recipes um they're
they have their different effects on the
class so with up with down sample and up
sample it's gonna
affect the sample size of your data
um they also have different effects on
it so some of them
might not deal with multi-class such as
rose sampling
and also you can actually control the
ratio of classes so
you know you might not want a perfectly
even classes you might allow for some um
roomed wiggle room let's go to the
uh was it tidy the yardstick package
and again with the yardstick package um
the main thing
is looking at the i guess what the the
main thing was r u c
auc and sensitivity and specificity
have different ways of being computed um
with multi-class classification
so with roc aoc or auc
there's different ways so with
multi-class they have my
macro and micro uh
weighted averages essentially it's kind
of doing i'll leave one out so it's
saying
um it's saying like class a versus the
rest
or class b versus the rest and then
averaging it out
okay so our model finally finished um
tuning
and now we can look at the final
evaluation so if we actually do just
like a collect
metrics we can see pretty high actually
85
accuracy with the roc aoc score of 74.
um if we look at our original um
our original thing it has basically the
similar rsa uc score
and now we can actually look at our
final confusion matrix just to make sure
not doing anything crazy so collect
predictions and then we can do a conf
mat truth is equal to house estimate is
equal to dot pred
plus and again you can see how
um it's not doing as well as we liked
it's mostly only predicting uh
gryffindor
but it's still capturing um some of the
classes such as
slytherin so this is one of the problems
with multi-class classification
um it requires a lot of tuning of the
model and also evaluating
um with confusion matrices it's very
difficult
but um generally you need to prioritize
what classes you want to
um luckily predict and deal with it uh
depending on your business applications
so i know this is a pretty quick video
but i'll see you guys next week and tidy
on